[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 culture tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 11 juin au
mois de juillet la commanderie connaîtra
quelques turbulences des danseurs
professionnels et amateurs vous feront
découvrir le lieu avec un autre regard
ils sont en ce moment en pleine création
depuis vingt ans la mission danse de
saint quentin en yvelines fait entrer la
discipline au coeur des écoles un moyen
de se découvrir et de partager un conte
monté par et pour des personnes en
situation de handicap
les médiathèques du territoire et le
pôle art et handicap 78 92 ont mis en
place un projet artistique et culturel
la danse comme forme d'empathie la
commanderie comme lieu chorégraphique en
juillet le site saint quentinois vous
emmène au coeur de son état de son
espace la mission danse a invité la
chorégraphe tatiana julia a proposé une
performance participative ce week-end
l'heure était à la création michael et
demi d'euros pour les images on regarde
une posture est il ya une globalité la
posture mais ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il y avait aussi des
détails prendre conscience de son corps
de celui des autres et de l'espace dans
un mois ces franciliens font partie
intégrante d'une création
j'aime bien rencontrer les chorégraphes
et faire partie du processus de création
de l'oeuvre voilà en plus cela c'est une
situe du coup c'est super intéressant
d'explorer aussi l'endroit où j'aime
bien faire des expériences avec
l'univers d'un chorégraphe et en plus en
plein air ou dans un lieu particulier
ils sont une quinzaine à se mêler à des
danseurs professionnels
le 6 juillet ils joueront turbulences
pensé par la chorégraphe tatiana julien
une création qui s'adapte au lieu de
représentation l'oeuvre a d'abord été
pensé pour le château de vincennes créer
un projet très immersif très
et
plein de liberté et de joie est quelque
chose d'assez festif avec le public où
il ya une première déambulation le
public circule librement dans tout le
bâtiment ils visitent le bâtiment mais
par la danse on a été complètement
emporté emballé par cette proposition
puisque on n'est pas dans une
représentation classique avec le public
d'un côté et le spectacle de l'autre la
la danse elle est partout elle entoure
le spectateur et niveau des sensations
la commanderie c'est un lieu fait pour
des propositions inédites original
singulière la déambulation se terminera
en une fête dans la chapelle avec un dj
des performances de danseurs les
premières turbulences sont attendus à la
commanderie pour 21h avec nous en
plateau deux invités dominique benhaim
bonjour vous êtes responsable de la
mission danse et patricia dutertre
bonjour vous êtes enseignante à l
encours alors on va parler ensemble de
danse à l'école mais juste avant denis
benayoun et à la commanderie le projet
turbulences
un beau projet j'imagine la magnifique
projet je crois que presque tout a été
dit par tatiana julien ou par fanny
debré de la mission danse effectivement
maintenant on attend les spectateurs le
6 juillet pour une déambulation sur
l'ensemble du site de la commanderie et
ensuite un rendez-vous dans la chapelle
donc ça sera un lieu un petit peu
atypique avec des danseurs et pour faire
la fête avec le public aussi accompagné
d'un dj les d'autres projets
participatifs comme ça qui sont en
préparation turbulences va clôturer la
saison 2
de danse à la commanderie mais oui nous
mettons en place l'année prochaine
un autre projet avec claude brumachon et
benjamin lamarche et chorégraphe qui ont
beaucoup oeuvré et débuté en fait à
saint quentin en yvelines et il nous a
proposé de recréer une pièce qu'il a
créé il ya une quinzaine d'années pour
deux danseurs professionnels et là il
propose de le recréer avec des amateurs
donc ça sera le festin ça s'appelle le
festin un certain nombre d'ateliers tout
au long de l'année et une représentation
début juillet 2020 aussi à la commande
affaire à suivre de plein vent vous
donnera des nouvelles alors vous êtes là
on peut être ce soir c'est pour parler
de votre projet qui implique un tout
autre public
ça va de la maternelle au lycée les 15
et 16 juin prochain 20 classes
saint-quentinoise vous montrer à leurs
proches des instants de danse
il participa danse à l'école un parcours
piloté par l'agglomération
un parcours qui à 20 ans denis bnm est
ce que déjà on peut présenter en
quelques mots
oui tout à fait en france ce dispositif
d'un dispositif national au départ
qu'elle aimait été mis en place dans les
années 90 à 85 86 par un groupe de
réflexion qui étaient issus des
directions danses et musiques du
ministère d inspection générale de
l'éducation nationale et de la direction
des écoles accompagnés de danseurs c'est
vraiment un dispositif la danse à
l'école c'est pas on danse dans les
écoles
c'est vraiment tout un dispositif
pédagogique de qui donne en fait la part
belle à l'enfant aux jeunes dans son
espace dans l'espace de l'école en lien
avec ses collègues
kolko oui ses copines de la classe et
d'autres dans l'école aussi patricia du
théâtre vous êtes enseignante à l'école
maternelle willy brandt à elancourt vous
en êtes venus comment à participer à ce
projet c'est vous qui êtes allé vers la
mission la mission qui est venue vers
vous alors je suis allé vers la mission
c'est ma deuxième participation à ce
projet cette année donc dans mon école
via une structure un peu particulière il
ya une unité pour enfants autistes et
avec ma collègue nous avions dans l'idée
de partager cette aventure humaine
autour de la danse donc notre
participation était motivé par ce projet
de collaboration entre nos deux classes
et autour de la danse qui est une
formidable ouverture pour les enfants de
cette classe d'enfants autistes et aussi
pour mes élèves puisque ça permet de
lier la danse a beaucoup d'apprentissage
de grande section en l'occurrence
justement il ya un aspect éducatif tout
à l'international exactement la danse
entre dans les programmes de l'éducation
nationale et la façon dont est construit
ce projet nous permet effectivement de
faire des liens avec toutes les
disciplines qui sont abordés au niveau
de la maternelle
voilà alors le thème de cette 20e
édition brodait nos horizons
est-ce qu'on peut expliquer aux petits
points importants déjà sur un territoire
on est quand même un territoire de 12
communes
il y a huit communes qui seront
représentés cette année dans le projet
danse à l'école et comment on part du
grand au plus petit pour s'attribuer ses
horizons différents en fonction des
projets de classe en fait ils sont
on a un thème commun et chacun le
décline à sa façon avec les danseurs
professionnels qui accompagnent puisque
chaque enseignant est accompagné d'un
danseur professionnel en justement parmi
eux d'anciens professionnels elle est là
depuis deux ans agathe sofa belle je
sens que je veux qu'on prononce bien et
il accompagne passarella c'est ce
parcours est aussi possible grâce à eux
j'imagine grâce à ces artistes à fait à
gastes faux fadel est une des cinq
personnes reconnues comme
transmetteur ça se dit il c'est pas de
la danse à l'école
donc c'était très important pour nous de
travailler avec des gens qui
comment dire qui de le développent mais
qui sont aussi à l'origine de ce projet
danse à l'école donc agathe fait partie
de ce groupe donc nous lui avons demandé
dans plusieurs chorégraphes sont succédé
bien sûr beaucoup pendant les faits
pendant que jean christophe blaton
leclerc génie et agathe est là depuis
donc deux ans à coordonner
artistiquement le projet danse à l'école
j'imagine que les élèves at one fabriqué
avec impatience pour tout à fait
présenter à leurs parents ce qu'ils ont
fait tout au long de l'année
alors pour présenter à leurs parents ça
c'est sûr mais aussi pour partager avec
leurs camarades leur vécu parce que
c'est un vécu d'une année pour nous le
projet danse a commencé en septembre
octobre dans ma classe donc
effectivement c'est une aventure qui a
duré un certain nombre de mois donc ils
ont très envie de partager à la fois au
sein de ma classe avec les
petits-enfants de l'unité d'enfants
autistes et les familles aussi envie de
partager tout cela
les familles des deux classes parce que
c'est aussi l'occasion pour ces familles
là de se rencontrer dans le cadre de ce
projet il ya aussi eu des ateliers
parents enfants au sein de l'école a
déjà été une formidable étape dans le
projet et la basse et la suite et les
fins enfin pas de l'aventuré en tout cas
pour cette année là autour de la danse
alors c'est la danse à l'école vous
disais ce n'est pas que danser à l'école
ça dépasse cela ils ont pu découvrir des
spectacles tout au long de l'année c'est
aussi les faire entrer dans des lieux
qui n'auraient pas
ça leur fait partager ce qui est très
important dans le projet c'est aussi ce
que ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
relation aux oeuvres
il suffit pas de pratiquer en atelier il
faut aussi aller aiguiser son sens
critique découvrir des univers des
univers de chorégraphes bien évidemment
différent et donc c'est ce qui est
proposé quand on monte le projet d'aller
voir deux trois quatre spectacles selon
les possibilités de chaque classe sur le
territoire de saint quentin dans
différents lieux du territoire qui
propose des spectacles
certains de vos élèves vous ont surpris
sur leur ressenti vous rêvez pas ce
qu'ils font beaucoup de lien entre ce
qu'il voit au spectacle et ceux qui
vivent avec le danseur qui est intervenu
un certain nombre de fois dans ma classe
et ils ont du coup une capacité
d'analysé du spectacle petit ma surprise
parce qu'ils ont acquis un certain
nombre de compétences dans le domaine de
la de la danse qu'il n'avait pas
forcément départ et pour le coup c'est
vrai que oui c'était vraiment une belle
aventure d'aller aussi voir ses
spectacles pour les enfants qui sont
très jeunes et qui n'ont pas forcément
l'occasion cordiale et ça donne envie de
retourner à l'école tout ça merci à
toutes les vedettes revenu sur ce
plateau je rappelle de beinheim êtes la
responsable de la mission danse de 50
ans de vie patricia du terrain tout est
enseignante sur le territoire et on
parlait du dispositif danse à l'école
qui fête cette année ses 20 ans c'est un
anniversaire aussi pour le cycliste le
championnat intercollèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale de déclic
théâtre fait lui aussi ses 20 ans cette
année le vendredi 14 juin quatre
collèges s'affronteront dans les phases
finales ça se passe à la merise de
trappes
on écoute le responsable du secteur
d'improvisation il était l'invité de
grégory canal et le 5 juin dernier
c'est la rencontre avant tout ça voilà
on parle d'affrontements tout ça mais ça
c'est le folklore pour le public nous
c'est vrai que ce qui nous intéresse et
ce qui les intéresse eux ils le
comprennent très vite c'est la rencontre
après le qui va gagner
j'ai envie de dire quand on est sur
scène on a déjà tout gagné c'est leur
moment phare de l'année l'opéra des
enfants revient pour sa 17e édition des
élèves des écoles du territoire vont
tous se retrouver ce samedi 15 juin sur
la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cette année le choix s'est porté sur une
création locale l'histoire de pinocchio
penser en 2007 par étienne perruchon un
mot du président de l'association pour
la promotion de la musique classique il
est au micro de marylène iapichino cette
année alors cette année nous avons un
coeur de 358 enfants on a donc on est
très content parce que c'est la première
année où on a des deux villes qui ont
intégré saint quentin en 2016
on a donc deux et que deux classes
pardon de des clayes sous bois
nous avons deux classes de plaisir du
quartier du vélib ou de plaisir en fait
l'objectif c'est que ces enfants
chantent ensemble se connaissent les uns
les autres c'est en fait un projet qui
est à vocation surtout du vivre ensemble
du social de leur permettre de découvrir
les grands là la grande culture
une table ronde le magicien merlin des
chevaliers les éléments qui font marquer
l'histoire bien connus du roi arthur
l'oeuvre créée en 191 par henry purcell
a inspiré jérôme correas et les paladins
pour cette nouvelle création
ils se sont associés au chorégraphe
louis barrault et des artistes amateurs
là aussi le roi arthur était à découvrir
le samedi 8 juin au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et nous avons
assisté à une répétition
[Musique]
le roi arthur à la recherche de sa chair
emeline compter au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
après hama dj de endel jérôme correas et
les paladins s'attaque à l'oeuvre de
henry purcell une création commandée par
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
à laquelle s'est associé le chorégraphe
louis barrault c'est un opéra donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya un livre est donc une
histoire
or moi j'ai beaucoup l'habitude en tant
que chorégraphe de plutôt mettre en
place des formes on va dire abstraite
c'est à dire que j'aime bien ne pas
chercher à raconter une histoire mais
plutôt à organiser dans l'espace des
formes des balades et des mouvements des
relations une création débuté il ya
plusieurs mois sur scène quatre solistes
professionnels et 300 amateurs des
adultes et des élèves des écoles du
territoire
ces quatre écoles qui sont très
différentes ça c'est aussi intéressant
puisque c'est d'aider des mondes qui
n'ont rien à voir
voilà il ya des enfants il ya des
enfants qui viennent de milieux très
aisé d'autres au contraire beaucoup
moins et c'est des gens qui se
rencontrent sur scène et qui d'un seul
coup sûr le plateau se retrouve un état
un état d'égalité totale presque je me
suis adapté en proposant des choses
simples et en même temps c'est parfois
les choses les plus simples qui demande
le plus de concentration et d'attention
vis à vis du groupe en fait pendant plus
d'une heure les artistes vous emmèneront
au coeur de l'angleterre
tout en se questionnant sur les idéaux
de la chevalerie la solidarité et la
justice
on reste à saint quentin en yvelines
pour évoquer un autre projet que nos
nouveaux invités un projet à destination
des personnes en situation de handicap
aux manettes le pôle art et handicap 78
92 avec sa responsable elodie chaffin et
le réseau des médiathèques de
l'agglomération représentait ce soir par
sébastien richard vous êtes chargé du
développement des publics spécifiques
comme ça bonsoir
alors ce projet qu'on ait son
aboutissement dans les jours à venir les
13 et 20 juin prochain ils seront sur
scène déjà comment est venue l'idée
loties d'un tel projet alors l'idée a
été vraiment une co-construction c'est
le réseau des médiathèques qui est venu
vers nous vers le polar un handicap qui
c'est un dispositif en fait qui a été
mis en place par le théâtre eurydice qui
situé à plaisir et la mission principale
du polar handicap c'est de favoriser
l'accès de la culture à tous
en créant des partenariats entre les
établissements médico sociaux et les
établissements culturels
donc c'est à ce titre là que le réseau
des médiathèques est venu vers nous donc
c'est soleil nivard que je remplace
pendant son congé maternité qui a monté
ce projet et du coup sébastien va
pouvoir plus en parler que moi sur un
peu le live la nation justement c'est là
s'aiment pourquoi viser ce public-là
particulièrement alors nous donc dans le
réseau des médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines
on a
une politique d'action culturelle
diriger vers les publics spécifiques
donc
il a défini un certain nombre de public
il ya des personnes en apprentissage du
français il ya des personnes en
insertion professionnelle
et puis on a aussi décidé de toucher
aussi les personnes en situation de
handicap
cd c'était des il y avait déjà des
partenariats qui existait entre les
médiathèques et les établissements
médico sociaux
mais en fait c'est partenariat n'avaient
pas de lien ensemble sur le territoire
et là on a essayé de trouver un projet
fort voilà en cohérence alors justement
les établissements médico-sociaux vous
en avait parlé il y en a cinq qui sont
rattachés au projet et je vous propose
dans l'écouté deux d'entre eux il est en
répétition ce matin il s'agit du service
d'accueil de jour
handicapé le foyer des sols ils sont
tous deux sur magny les hameaux
l'idée de pouvoir en fait mais les
impôts divers établissements sociaux
médico-sociaux et personne aussi
vieillissante
autour d'un projet artistique alors
comme nous nous sommes s'est attaché à
tout ce qui est artistique de conte à 10
et pourquoi pas catherine kabylie à et
alexandre ont été très motivés par ce
projet ils ont l'habitude d'écouter des
histoires et des contes à l'occasion de
veiller et à des activités pendant la
journée et du coup ils ont bien voulu
essayer d'être en scène
alors là c'est un long travail de
préparation j'imagine autour d'un conte
les artistes de paris un petit mot
peut-être sur ce compte
oui donc du coup c'est une reprise de
des musiciens braine le comte de
musiciens de brême qui a été réécrit par
la comédienne qui travaillent sur le
projet donc marc et sylvia manuel et en
fait on aimait bien se content parce que
ça pas mal de thématiques qui concerne
notre projet notamment ses des animaux
qui
qui sont un peu exclu parce que ils sont
fatigués et les fermiers ne veulent plus
d'eux et puis au final ils s'entraident
pour faire quelque chose de beau et puis
c'était un peu l'idée de ce qu'on
voulait faire
alors là sûr c'est quand ils sont partis
autour du kamishibaï une petite
explication sur ce que c est ce que
sébastien et le 10 août à multi valls et
c'est une technique de comptes japonaise
donc c'est avec un petit théâtre en bois
qui se ferme avec des volets donc on
ouvre et puis après il ya des planches
d'illustrations et derrière on a le
texte ce qui permet en fait de ne pas se
tourner tout le temps pour voir le texte
et donc du coup voilà c'est beaucoup
plus fluide bon là on l'a on l'a
retravaillé c'est ça sort du cadre le
projet s'appelle sortir du cadre
donc du coup il ya des comédiens qui
sont enregistrés sous été touché à
quatre disciplines artistiques
donc on a fait appel à trois artistes
alexis prugne ans qui a lui a animé un
atelier de musique pour
la mise en musique du compte il ya aussi
eu donc permis de construire avec adèle
et patoche qui ont elles travailler avec
le foyer des sols pour la manipulation
des marionnettes et enfin le tome 6 dai
a été réalisée par le snj h dont on a vu
le témoignage tout à l'heure du chef de
service qui a créé réaliser lui même
donc le but est donc c'est le le support
en bois du théâtre et les planches ont
quant à elles été réalisée par donc maël
nortier qui est l'éducatrice du assayas
suit voilà du même site avec trois
résident donc au sein des médiathèques
parce que les olives est avant tout fait
de a à z c'est vraiment un projet dont
se sont servis des illustrations des
livres des médiathèques pour pour créer
les planches les buvettes hakkar ont
participé donc c'est vraiment une
co-construction quoi tout le monde a mis
la main à la pâte enfin les ateliers ont
eu lieu au sein des médiathèques pour
favoriser le hors les murs et donc voilà
c'est vraiment un partenariat avec les
quatre médiathèques et les cinq
établissements médico-sociaux immédiate
et compte apporter les lieux leurs
connaissances
de leurs fonds et littéraire aussi
comment ça s'est passé donc oui donc
célébrités caire qui ont décidé du choix
du compte
et puis on a apporté les lieux mais
aussi les ressources humaines entre
guillemets donc on a beaucoup participé
aux ateliers chacun et puis même lors du
spectacle ça continuera en fait il ya il
ya des écarts qui sont qui sont parties
du spectacle mais ce n'est pas terminé
il ya eu seize ateliers ça va donner
deux représentations
est-ce que tout est prêt alors ce matin
c'était justement la répétition
c'était l'occasion pour chaque les
quatre ateliers de se réunir et de
tester pour voir justement ce que ça
allait donner
et le résultat moi j'ai trouvé il était
à là c'était convaincant
voilà moi je tenais à souligner
justement le gros investissement de tous
aussi bien les professionnels des
établissements médico sociaux des
médiathèques mais aussi les artistes
ce qu'il faut savoir que en fait il ya
eu du temps personnel des artistes en
gros temps personnel notamment pour
adapter le conte c'est marc silva qui
l'a fait sur son personnel en or du des
ateliers la mise en musique du compte a
été fait par alex et prugnaud et la
construction des marionnettes n'a pas
été fait au sein des ateliers mai par la
compagnie a permis de construire donc
voilà c'est vraiment un gala samedi les
deux représentations qui vont être
données le grand public ne pourra pas le
voir mais est-ce que vu l'avancée de ce
projet un jour les portes s'ouvrir aux
saint quentinois pour venir voir ce qui
s'est créée on espère mais donc il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver une salle un peu
plus grande déjà voilà c'est ça et puis
voilà on a beaucoup de projets aussi
dans le réseau des médiathèques on
espère qu'on prend on espère vraiment qu
on peut continuer suis là parce que ça a
mobilisé sa bien mobiliser les biotech
et on est tous très contents du résultat
donc on espère que ça se prouve sa se
poursuivre mais qui se soucie de vente
était est ce qu'un tel projet va être
renouvelée je pense que la réponse a été
donnée
alors merci à tous les deux d'être
revenez sur ce plateau pour nous
présenter un projet commun du réseau des
médiathèques de 50 ans de vie et du
polar et handicap sosie et 92 on espère
un jour pouvoir y assister dans une
salle et on passe maintenant à solidays
des conférences sans association 80
concerts 900 ça revient à la fin du mois
à paris longchamp un festival organisé
en partenariat avec la région ile de
france depuis sa création plus de 3
millions de spectateurs ont foulé les
pelouses de l'hippodrome 37 millions de
personnes vivent avec le vih dans le
monde et même
l'accès aux traitements évoluer
progresse il ya encore 40 % des malades
dans le monde qui n'ont pas accès aux
traitements
solidays c'est dans moins de trois
semaines de festival en faveur de la
lutte contre le sida revient pour une
21e édition
c'est aussi un rendez-vous qu'on attend
tous parce que ça c'est un week-end qui
fait du bien c'est un oui cannatella
public c'est un week-end où on se sent
plus proche des autres où il ya de la
bienveillance de l'empathie ça me permet
d'assister à des colloques de rencontrer
des gens ou ensuite d'acheter des
bouquins intéressant qui me permette de
grandir de m'éduquer et puis ensuite de
repasser à la musique il ya tout qui est
condensée dans ce festival cette année
encore l'ile-de-france et partenaires un
soutien à hauteur de 800 mille euros la
région est particulièrement touché
chaque jour 7 franciliens découvrent
leur séropositivité
nous avons un grand festival de musique
populaire française et ça est
indépendant et ça c'est très important
culturellement c'est très important
c'est un festival qui a un supplément
d'âme un supplément d'âme parce que la
question de la lutte contre le sida est
majeur tu l'as dit pour l'ile-de-france
80 concerts répartis sur 3 jours le
festival attire chaque année des
nouveaux artistes mais aussi des fidèles
hocus pocus se reforme pour une tournée
anniversaire solidays c'est un des plus
beaux festivals qu'on ait fait on a
vraiment des souvenirs particuliers où
on s'est retrouvé à jouer dans quarante
cinquante mille personnes
on nous a souvent programmés sur des
débuts de projets aussi quand s'était
pas lancé par exemple sur alta où cette
incroyable sous le chapiteau en ce
moment on est à fond sur l'engagement
c'est un truc qui est qu'on a compris
c'est un truc qui est venu avec le
succès qu'on a compris en se disant on a
un gros audimat
il ya des grands enjeux en ce moment
dans notre époque actuelle donc il vous
qu'on fasse partie de ça pour être
solidaire c'est du 21 au 23 juin à paris
longchamp l'an dernier le festival avait
battu un record de fréquentation plus de
212 mille spectateurs s'étaient déplacés
du 14 au 23 juin c'est la quatorzième
édition de maisons laffitte jazz
festival on compte onze concerts sont
prévus dont une soirée en hommage à
michel petrucciani le pianiste français
disparus il ya de cela vingt ans pour la
première date un trio composé d'artistes
internationalement reconnues on écoute
l'un d'entre eux richard bona
[Musique]
baby même
non
[Musique]
une exposition de peintures
photographies quelle sabine à janot de
saint-alban revient à la galerie saint
simon de versailles l'artiste révèle ses
techniques ses techniques basées sur du
dessin à main levée elle expose jusqu'au
16 juin
des mélodies simples évocatrice
nostalgiques ou encore avant gardiste à
la ferme de bel ébat le trio bora
présente un concert en hommage au trio
d'anches de paris une formation de
chambre emblématique de
l'entre-deux-guerres le rendez vous est
donné ce samedi 15 juin à 20h30 et la
ferme de bel ébat vous dévoile sa
nouvelle saison le mardi 18 juin à 20h30
des rendez-vous qui vont mêler théâtre
classique théâtre contemporain musique
humour conte cirque et bien plus encore
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]